now the aaa has described foxton as the
hot spot for holiday hell with traffic
hoping to use the channel tunnel
starting to back up let's speak to john
keith who's from euro channel john thank
you so much for talking to us so what
has gone wrong here
well that's a very difficult question to
answer because as far as we're concerned
everything is going right um our service
is working as it should we're running
four departures per hour we are carrying
the traffic that was forecast for the
day and in fact we're slightly ahead of
the forecast as we speak
so once people get to our terminal get
to our check-in then they're moving
through
as we would normally plan
we recognize because we're seeing the
the coverage that there are significant
difficulties on the roads um and it's
difficult to answer
why they're there because our service is
running as it should so there's
absolutely no change in the amount of
people getting on the euro tunnel from
now
and
let's say this week for instance the
number of people per hour
no
we are running our normal service four
trains per hour and we're filling them
um and the people when they arrive at
our check-in are taking about 90 minutes
to go from the check-in
to their departure
we advise people to turn up
about two hours before their book
departure so we're well within the sort
of margin for error on that side of
things the only thing that's changed in
travel terms and this has been commented
on a number of times is of course that
people are having to go through a
passport control to get into the eu now
but that's included within the 90
minutes so
it's not actually affecting their their
journeys because we've got the the
resourcing from the the path to cover
that
in terms of this weekend i imagine that
one would plan ahead um because one
would assume a lot more people will be
trying to get on the euro channel going
on holiday so did you plan ahead and did
you put more people on post as it were
absolutely in fact we brought additional
staff through from our terminal in
france because france has been quieter
friday and saturday it starts to get a
bit busier this afternoon as people come
back from their holidays um but we've
had additional staff around the terminal
um but we've had additional services or
we've had entertainment for children
we've had a singer in the the terminal
building
live music all the way through
we're providing obviously
refreshment water
in critical areas with people are
getting too hot
additional services also for people with
pets lots more shade lots more drinking
bowls and so we we've put on a lot of
extra stuff which we always do in the
summer
um and we've we've put on additional
trains by comparison to the middle of
the week in uh automotive winter so that
we're at peak service right the way
through this weekend
with additional support to get people
through the terminal as i say when
they're reaching the terminal they're
moving through as they should and we're
filling all of those trains
we recognize those difficulties outside
and that there is a lot of traffic on
the road um
but when people get to us they're going
through as they would expect to
when i spoke to our reporter at the
beginning of this hour i think it was
about ten past one quarter past one she
said it was taking people about two
hours
to get onto that train
so
that's what we that's what we say to
people expect about two hours arrive two
hours before your departure um
and you know when people do that then
that's fine we're actually averaging
somewhere around 90 minutes so we're
within that
time frame on our terminal so the the
the service that we're running is the
service that we
advertised it's booked so everybody who
is traveling today has a reservation now
they're struggling to get to the
terminal and so they're people are
turning up late for their book departure
but that's not a problem we're accepting
them in order of arrival and to make
sure that they're not held up by the
fact that their their departure has
already gone so where is the problem
because there is you acknowledge there
is a problem
no i i acknowledge there's a lot of
traffic on the roads
i can only talk to you about what we're
doing ourselves and how our service is
running and our service is running as
it's planned to run four departures per
hour that's peak service with traffic
moving from the check-in to the
departure in about 90 minutes two hours
if some people are
experiencing slightly longer but that's
within the the margin for error that is
set within the
expectation
so
we i can't answer the question of why
there is congestion all around the area
the the traffic is turning up and is
being carried across the channel as
planned
so this
do you think that this situation what
we're seeing this weekend is going to
happen every single time there's a peak
every single time we have a busy weekend
and going forward every single summer
well
there are things which have changed in
travel so certainly it does take longer
um
on average what specifically what
specifically has changed in travel and
why does it take longer border controls
there are now border controls so there
there will be uh additional constraints
on travel so is that what was our
problem here well from our perspective
recognizing that there would be more
time needed to get through border
controls we've actually capped the
volume of traffic that we will take so
that we're carrying less than we did in
2018 for example
so
the the measures you know the
contingencies that we put in place are
to ensure that traffic continues to flow
through at the
the speed of our uplift capability which
is four trains per hour um
and that's happening on our terminal now
quite what's going on on the on the
motorway since friday really and
we know that there was a very major
accident on the on the motorway there's
a lot of additional trucks on the roads
at the moment that normally wouldn't be
there at a weekend
and so when you mix the truck traffic
and the passenger traffic so you've got
very high levels of trucks that
shouldn't be there very high and
expected levels of passenger traffic the
mix of the two means that there is
congestion um but so is it it's not
necessarily related to
the the number of people trying to get
across the channel so is the issue
there's a big traffic jam there's a big
queue on the road that's related to
road traffic
and the number of trucks on the road or
is it those border checks making it
longer for people to get on to the euro
tunnel the the issue on the roads is
traffic um there
normally uh the the truck traffic
travels during the middle of the week um
and is cleared by friday evening when
the passenger traffic starts to build
and unfortunately on friday this week
there was a very major accident that
closed the m20 for several hours and
that truck traffic was then stuck on the
motorway being managed in operation
brock
being cared for in operation but taking
up space on the road system that would
normally be available for passenger
vehicles
so with that um the situation we're
observing is that there is far more
traffic
in general numbers mixed of uh trucks
and passengers on the roads and that's
causing congestion
the the the transport service that we
run the shuttle service is running as
it's planned
how is it running as it's planned if
there's a lot of traffic
well we plan to carry um 7 000
passenger cars today um we plan to carry
them
at a regular rate throughout the day and
we are on our
timetable slightly ahead we carry a few
hundred cars more
than we would have expected to carry by
this time of day
so the you know the the plan that we go
through is somebody makes a booking they
get added to the number of
vehicles we're going to carry we provide
the capacity to carry that number of
vehicles and then we keep a measure of
that through the day
and that's what we do that is the plan
and that plan is working it's on time so
once people reach our terminal where we
start to take care of them they are
moving through as it was planned
it's it's it's very confusing
and i'm sure you can appreciate this
that
you're seeing all these issues people
are spending
at the port of dover for instance i know
that's not at foxton but they spend the
night in their cars waiting for this
whenever we ask someone what's going on
what's the issue here the buck is passed
do you think that it's time now someone
took responsibility for
no no i
think i'm taking responsibility for what
we are responsible for we are
responsible for moving traffic across
the channel from once it gets to our
check-in uh until it it reaches the
other side and vice versa we've got a
busy afternoon in france bringing people
back into the uk again
so
we plan that we we
we have a set number of spaces that we
will provide travel for
can i just jump in there yeah can i just
jump in that when you say we we're
operating at peak
what exactly do you mean by peak and how
do you tweak that according to the time
of year the time of day even
so the peak is when maximum demand uh
occurs and that's this weekend this is
the busiest weekend of the whole year
and peak uh service for us is providing
four trains four shuttle departures per
hour in each direction
um so
that's the peak outside of peak we might
only be providing three or two or
sometimes just one departure per hour
because there isn't any demand for it so
we would be running empty trains if we
ran any other way
so at this time we
we prepare to carry four full trains per
hour and then we keep another train in
reserve just in case one of those has a
an issue of failure
we can always move another train into
service
so
our peak service is is there to carry
maximum numbers of passengers
and to provide flexibility should
anything go wrong so we don't cancel
departures we simply move people onto
the next one so whoever turns up at our
terminal today with the booking to
travel today will be carried to france
today